France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe en cette semaine de
mobilisation en Russie dans le conflit
ukrainien et donc de tension
internationales maximales nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir depuis l'ONU à New
York à l'issue de l'assemblée générale
le chef euro de la diplomatie européenne
espagnole Joseph Borel monsieur le Haut
représentant pour les affaires
étrangères et la défense merci d'être
avec nous
bonjour
Merci à VOUS bonjour Merci à vous avant
votre nomination vous étiez déjà une
figure bien connue des institutions
européennes vous avez été élu au
Parlement européen en 2004 vous avez
présidé ce Parlement chez vous en
Espagne vous êtes un ténor de la vie
politique depuis les années 70 époque à
laquelle vous avez rejoint le Parti
socialiste à ce titre vous avez
participé à plusieurs gouvernements vous
étiez le ministre des Affaires
étrangères de Pedro Sanchez quand vous
avez été appelé à revenir à Bruxelles
voilà alors même à New York City vous
avez dû organiser une réunion d'urgence
des ministres des Affaires étrangères
sur l'Ukraine avec des référendums
d'annexion prévus par la Russie qui ont
buté vendredi et vont se tenir jusqu'au
27 septembre dans les régions sous
contrôle russe de Donesk Lougansk dans
l'est du pays de Kerson et japporiza
dans le sud en pleine agression
militaire l'Union européenne ne va pas
reconnaître sans doute ces référendums
mais qu'est-ce que ça va changer sans
doute pas
j'ai bien évidemment pourquoi tes
référendum comme ça convoqué à la
sauvette sans censue dans un pays en
guerre la moitié des gens ne sont partis
les autres
franchement comment peut-on imaginer
comme vous pouvez faire un référendum
des jours au lendemain
n'ont pas pareil connaître ça à cette
mascarade alors justement José Borel
Vladimir Poutine a fait ses annonces il
y a quelques jours il a surpris tout le
monde il a aussi annoncé la mobilisation
partielle des soldats alors c'est perçu
comme un avait de faiblesse mais c'est
aussi une très forte escalade de la part
du président russe malheureusement oui
malheureusement
à 300 000 hommes sous les drapeaux
d'après ce qu'on voit c'est plus qu'une
mobilisation c'est une rafle c'est une
rafle parce qu'on va très bien que les
gens ne sont pas très enthousiasmés pour
partir pour partir à la guerre
côté
interne fait face intégrer un colades de
son armée et
dangereuses parce que il faut voir
comment il va réagir alors le président
russe était absent de l'assemblée
générale de continue mais envoyer depuis
Moscou des messages pour le moins
menaçant alors s'il met sa menace
nucléaire à exécution et on pense
notamment à une frappe tactique sur une
petite ville ukrainienne comment
l'Europe avec la France d'ailleurs
puissance nucléaire va réagir
pour l'instant on est tous en train de
travailler pour que c'était scénario
noir mais c'est peu de
c'est ça qu'il faut faire mais non il
faut pas escalader
faire des déclarations qui poussent
mettre encore plus en danger dans une
équilibre déjà difficile il faut pas
dire et si vous faites ça nous ferons là
il faut éviter que ça arrive c'est pour
cela il faut tenir une politique à la
fois ferme mais cherchant une boîte de
sortie pour ce conflit
alors José Borel justement pour cette
politique ferme on a vu qu'il y a eu
cette formidable contre-offensive de
l'armée ukrainienne qui bénéficie du
soutien des Occidentaux Joe Biden
aujourd'hui dit qu'il est prêt envoyer
des blindés américains sur le sol
ukrainien en revanche c'est encore un
sujet tabou en Europe les Européens
doivent-ils envoyer plus de moyens
militaires en Ukraine et pourquoi pas
des chars allemands ou français
c'est un sujet sur lequel certains pays
n'ont pas voulu s'engager mais il y en a
d'autres qui ont envoyé beaucoup de
blindés la Pologne envoyé plus de 200
chars de l'époque soviétique qui sont
tout à fait opérationnels
dans les pays comme vous voulez le faire
d'autres qui ont pas voulu le faire mais
dans son ensemble l'Union européenne a
été
pourvoyeur d'armes avec une quantité et
des qualités aussi très importantes
l'Allemagne et la France
doivent-ils aujourd'hui ces deux pays
doivent-ils en envoyer davantage de
matériel militaires notamment des chats
vous avez annoncé un nouveau train de
sanction en réaction justement à ces
récentes décisions de la lumière Poutine
elle est 27 discute par exemple d'un
plafonnement du prix du pétrole russe
dans les prises sont envolés est-ce que
ça couperait la manne financière de
Moscou
Lane financière de Moscou commence à
diminuer elle avait beaucoup remonté au
début à cause de la forte augmentation
de mépris maintenant les prix des
pétrole il y a quelques jours j'étais à
nouveau au même niveau qu'avant la
guerre
mais si on calcule les entrées du budget
russe pendant le sept premières mois de
cette année le 8 premiers mois de cette
année on ne compare avec les routes
premiers mois de l'année dernière il y a
une diminution de 18%. le seuilé
compense plus la diminution des
quantités et ça va continuer comme ça à
la fin de l'année tous les pays
européens sauvent l'engrais se sont
engagés à ne plus acheter du pétrole
russe à aucun prix plus de pétrole russe
les gaz étaient les 40% de nos
importations russes
40%. maintenant il est à moins de 10% on
a diminué 30% de 30 points pour ponctuel
c'est énorme
c'est énorme n'aurait pas imaginé que
serait capable
dans une période étant assez courte
quelques mois de diminuer
75% et 40 à 10 les montants de nos
importations des gaz russe et ça va
continuer à diminuer la Russie n'a pas
de clients alternatifs pour les gâches
donc
ça va commencer à être un problème pour
l'argile vous voulez dire par là que le
plafonnement du prix du pétrole n'est
pas forcément une nécessité
de décider de l'Union européenne et là
elle est payée européenne sont là je
souhaite à décider de mettre une plafond
au prix du pétrole mais je peux dire que
si à la fin de l'année nous on achète
plus du pétrole pour nous les plafonds
plafond au peuple font c'est la même
chose d'accord parmi les sanctions
envisagées on parle de l'interdiction
des importations du diamant russe
l'exclusion de banque russe du système
international suisse l'exclusion de
nouvelles banques les Pays-Bas étaient
la Pologne
seraient en pointe pour demander des
mesures très fortes est-ce qu'il y a une
majorité aujourd'hui parmi les 27 pour
faire des sanctions encore plus dures
jusqu'en maintenant le européen ont
montré une unité rapide solide j'ai
jamais vu des décisions prises pour les
standards européens ont suivi et
tous l'unanimité qui a requise pour
pouvoir prendre des décisions
ça va être comme ça on va travailler
pour que ça continue à être comme ça tu
vois je dois reconnaître qu'il y a des
jardins pays qui ont des positions plus
les gens
plus faibles mais j'espère que l'unité
de européens va continuer et qu'on
pourra à trouver encore à nouveau train
de sanction on y travaille déjà ça
c'était une affaire de chez ta membre il
faut proposer au Conseil et c'est le
conseil qui décide donc on verra bien
j'espère que tous les pays vont
continuer à appuyer une politique de
contrainte économique technologiques et
financière alors il se trouve que le
premier ministre hongrois ultra
conservateur Victor Hormann plaide
aujourd'hui pour la fin des sanctions
contre la Russie avant la fin de l'année
est-ce que sa proximité avec Moscou est
en train de rompre les rangs européens
de l'autre côté et nier l'évidence qu'il
y a au moins un pays qui
semble n'est pas être favorable à la
poursuite des censions mais je suis au
combat de trouver une solution pour que
l'on puisse continuer à le faire alors
il y a peut-être demain un autre pays
qui sera défavorable aux sanctions un
pays qui inquiète la diplomatie
européenne c'est l'Italie pour les
élections législatives du 25 septembre
de ce dimanche la coalition de droite et
qui s'apprête à gagner avec certains
pays partis pardon qui sont prorus
est-ce que vous redoutez un virage
diplomatique de la part de Rome
plein respect de ces fusions que les
citoyens de tous les pays européens
prennent librement quand ils sont
convoqués aux urnes qui semblait ou pas
ça n'a pas d'importance l'important
c'est que les Italiens sont des citoyens
libres tu me démocratie quand c'est
choix
démocratiquement et il faut la respecter
quoi qu'il soit
quoi qu'il soit mais ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que c'est après ma
connaissance la connexion des droites
exprimer est clair et haut sont
compromis son engagement pour rester et
membre fidèles de l'Union européenne et
de l'Alliance olympique et qui m'a
défendu le position que lui en
européenne a pris vis-à-vis de la Russie
mais le contexte de la guerre du grain
ça c'est rassurant
alors revenons sur les Nations Unies si
vous voulez bien à l'assemblée générale
le président Emmanuel Macron a en juin
les pays non alignés à choisir le bon
camp dans le conflit ukrainien mais en
fait de plus en plus de pays contournent
les sanctions et se désolidarisent
finalement de ce bloc on constate notre
difficulté à convaincre et aussi
l'incapacité de l'ONU peut-être à
défendre le droit international
des batailles avec des arbres
qui coûtent des vies et il y a aussi une
bataille des idées
nous ici aux Nations Unies le diplomate
nous faisons des batailles pas avec les
épées mais avec les mots c'est la
bataille des idées c'est la bataille des
narratives aussi importante ça cause pas
des morts directement mais en fonction
de les positions politiques des uns et
des autres la guerre
durée plus longtemps et ben écoutez plus
de victimes encore dans cette bataille
de mots cette bataille des idées cette
bataille qu'on disait narrative et très
importantes il faut la gagner aussi une
fois la gagner pour ça il faut une
activité permanente intense pédagogique
en parlant avec tout le monde et en
démontant et la narrative ce que dit que
à l'épître de l'énergie de plus de la
nourriture c'est la cause de sanctions
occidentale c'est la cause de la guerre
c'est la cause de la guerre nos
sanctions
ne touche pas ni la nourriture ni les
fertilisons c'est vrai il y a beaucoup
de pays qui n'ont pas appliqué nos
censions il y en a même des pays qui
sont candidats à être membre de l'Union
européenne qui ne l'ont pas fait il y en
a d'autres sans avoir aucune obligation
de le faire l'ont fait mais cette
bataille là il faut la faire il faut la
gagner et on la régnera pas restant chez
eux chez nous on n'ira pas
parce que ils ont des problèmes les gens
du problème il y a des pays qui
s'arrêtent ils sont pas des fertilisants
ils sont trop chers l'énergie à monter
beaucoup comme chez nous d'ailleurs et
il faut s'expliquer quelles sont les
causes et quelles sont les conséquences
peut-être c'est pas engagé assez dans
cette bataille des idées il faut le
faire il faut le faire venir on a on l'a
fait beaucoup mais il faut continuer à
le faire parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
des pays qui ne sont pas tellement
préoccupés par les causes de la guerre
du comprenne très bien que une invention
c'était mal le revenu n'appuie pas la
Russie mais son préoccupés par la
conséquences aussi très bien mais moi
j'ai un problème et ils ont des
problèmes graves qui touchent à
l'alimentation de ses citoyens à des
prix très énergies qui sont
insoutenables il y a des pays qui n'ont
plus de gaz parce que le marché des gaz
sont tellement montré que sont expulsés
du marché
bon il faut il faut avoir comment y
faire face il faut les aider à faire
face il faut dépenser d'argent et pour
aider à des pays qui sont touchés d'une
façon dramatique pour les conséquences
de la guerre à faire face à
José Borel on aimerait avoir votre avis
sur l'évolution du dossier iranien
Emmanuel Macron à New York a rencontré
et Brahim raïti en barge donc de
l'assemblée générale pour relancer les
négociations on voit bien qu'ils sont
dans l'impasse aujourd'hui
c'était en vain et puis on a par
ailleurs dans l'actualité on voit ce
pouvoir iranien qui réprime les
manifestations et les femmes alors
ce tirant là cette république islamique
va devenir une puissance nucléaire
pour l'instant on n'est pas une
puissance nucléaire grâce au pacte
nucléaire que les Européens ont beaucoup
contribué à faire
et on a dépensé beaucoup de temps
d'énergie politique pour répartir ses
pattes là que
le président Trump
a détruite
c'est pas facile ils ont une énorme
défiance les gens oui mais qui nous dit
que si demain il y a une autre
administration américaine on va pas
revoir la même chose et de notre côté on
a fait tout ce qu'on peut pour approcher
des positions et des autres on y était
presque
avant l'été pendant l'été il y a eu des
proposition de côté Iraniens qui n'ont
pas aidé à aller dans la bonne direction
mais non à nouveau dans un impact je ne
pense pas qu'on va en sortir très vite
merci à vous de cet entretien Joseph
Borel on se retrouve dans quelques
secondes à Strasbourg pour notre débat
consacré à la crise énergétique
justement et pouvoir d'achat des
Européens à tout de suite
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre ici depuis
Strasbourg au Parlement européen pour
notre débat consacré à la crise
énergétique conséquence directe de la
guerre en Ukraine et personne n'était
épargné en Allemagne interdiction de se
chauffer ou de la de 19 degrés dans tous
les bâtiments publics en Espagne les
lumières des vitrines de magasins
devront être éteinte dès 22h en France
on ferme des piscines et la Commission
européenne aussi un recommande des
économies d'énergie sévères à tous au
moment des heures de grande consommation
objectives évidemment éviter des
coupures et le blackout oui le 30
septembre les ministres européens de
l'énergie vont se réunir à nouveau pour
discuter des mesures d'urgence proposées
par la Commission européenne dans son
grand discours sur l'état de l'Union
Ursula van der le yen avait annoncé des
pistes pour réduire la facture
énergétique un plafonnement du revenu
des producteurs d'électricité qui
utilisent le nucléaire et les
renouvelables c'est donc une
contribution une taxation aussi sur les
super profits booster par la hausse des
prix de l'énergie elle concernera
également donc les producteurs d'énergie
fossiles et elle rapporterait 140
milliards d'euros à tous les Européens
répartis sur les 27 États membres est-ce
que cela va suffire pour assurer un
hiver serein et suffisamment chauffer
pour les Européens voilà nous allons
poser la question à nos invités de
députés européens aujourd'hui
Ernest hourtaz ou ne bonjour vous êtes
Espagnol et vous êtes du groupe des
Verts et votre pays inconnue une hyper
inflation énergétique et face à vous
Christian bousoy bonjour vous êtes du
groupe ici conservateur PPE vous êtes
roumain et président de la Commission de
l'industrie de la recherche et de
l'énergie est-ce que ce plan présenté
par la Commission européenne européenne
vous paraît à la hauteur de cette crise
énergétique sans précédent en Europe
bien sûr le plan n'a pas tous les
réponses c'est difficile l'Union
européenne n'a pas tous les réponses
parce qu'on dépend beaucoup de
événements international
la croissance dans de demande en Asie
bien sûr la guerre en Ukraine l'invasion
illégale de l'Ukraine par ici qui
influence beaucoup les prix
international et la situation mais ce
que la Commission européenne a présenté
aussi c'était retrouver dans le discours
de Madame président funderline une très
fort signal son de mesures très bonnes
pour calmer un peu la situation et pour
nous aider que dans cet hiver dans la
situation catastrophique ou la Russie
coupe totalement l'export de gaz pour
l'Europe on ne pourra avoir de
l'électricité de la chaleur pour les
citoyens pour les foyers et aussi pour
les industries essentiels est-ce que ça
va être le cas Ernest hurtazoune est-ce
que vraiment on va pas s'attendre à des
coupures de courant à ne pas pouvoir
bénéficier du chauffage dans tous les
foyers européens est-ce que cette
propositions sont suffisamment
ambitieuses et pas trop tardives aussi
un peu tardive mais je dirais qu'elles
vont dans le bon sens j'espère en tout
cas que les chefs d'État de gouvernement
vont les adopter le plus vite possible
en fait on avait deux problèmes un
problème c'était comment on fixait le
prix des différentes sources
d'électricité on les fixer tout au prix
du gaz de la plus haute donc ça ça avait
une répercussion sur la facture de
l'électricité énorme ce qu'on a fait
c'est plafonner en fait le prix des
différentes sources et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on avait demandé depuis depuis
beaucoup de mois et ça ça va être une
réalité et deuxièmement taxer le
surprofit et les deux mesures vont
peut-être apporter aux États membres 140
milliards c'est la chiffre le chiffre de
la Commission européenne a donné donc
voilà donc c'est redistribuer parce que
le but c'est de redistribuer au ménage
les plus
membres qui ont cette source de revenus
et qui vont distribuer au qui en ont
besoin donc voilà ça sera une bonne
façon de passer des verres d'essayer que
c'est un impact direct pour les ménages
et qu'on puisse passer les prochaines
mois avec une facture de l'électricité
beaucoup plus réduite donc ça va dans le
bon sens alors là vous parlez de la
facture et on va parler un peu plus
longuement mais parlons également des
sacrifices d'abord demandé aux Européens
objectifs pour les 27 c'est réduire de
15 % la consommation de gaz d'ici au 31
mars 2023 comment procède-t-on est-ce
que vous craignez des coupures
d'électricité vont-elles être
obligatoire dans les mois qui viennent
enfin nous demander de nous chauffer à
16 quoi en fait
oui pour le gaz c'est pas encore
obligatoire ça peut devient obligatoire
si c'est une situation de crise j'ai vu
déjà quelques pays comme l'Espagne comme
la France comme l'Allemagne qui ont venu
avec des plantes très très concrets dans
mon pays en Roumanie on va compenser
seulement
85% de la quantité qui a été consommée
l'année passée donc on a une
plafonnement une compensation total des
factures des citoyennes des petites
moyennes entreprises mais ce sera
jusqu'à intifive
5% de la consommation de l'année passée
il se passe quoi alors pour les 15 %
restants pour le 15 % si ils ne peuvent
pas s'il ne veut pas faire une
diminution ils vont payer le prix actuel
le prix pas comprendre c'est le prix du
marché qui est passé
vous craignez dans votre pays cet hiver
des coupures d'électricité j'espère non
parce que la Roumanie a une production
de gaz
nous avons 80% du nécessaire de la
production interne et aussi nous sommes
assez diversifiés mais si nous devons
faire partie d'une mécanisme de
solidarité et c'est une discussion très
importante et très intéressante bien sûr
ça se peut se passer mais pas pour les
citoyens pas pour les foyers mais je
crois que pas seulement dans mon pays
presque partout quelques industries
malheureusement sont dans le péril de
suspender leur activité j'espère pas une
clôture totale et perdent de l'emploi
oui alors il y a ça le fait de pour les
pour les citoyens eux-mêmes préparer les
gros pulls en quelque sorte pour pour
l'hiver est-ce qu'il peut être rude on a
l'impression quand même que du côté de
la Russie on est beauche le scénario
pour nous faire peur quand même d'une
Europe qui serait plongée dans le noir
et dans le froid et ce qui est-ce qu'il
risque d'exister un peu quand même ce
scénario moi pour les foyers je suis
plus inquiet du coup de la facture
d'électricité que vraiment d'avoir de
coupures moi je pense pas qu'il y a des
coupures les réserves sont sont dans un
bon état on a fait des plans
d'approvisionnement donc je pense qu'il
y aura pas de coupure mais ce qu'il
fallait c'était éviter une explosion
sociale du fait du coût de l'électricité
dans les ménages je suis plus inquiet je
suis d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit par certaines industries qui sont
extrêmement consommateurs d'énergie et
qui peuvent avoir des difficultés en
Allemagne par exemple il y a certains
qui ont déjà dû arrêter leur activité à
cause des coupures mais en tout cas pour
le long terme ce qui est très important
tente c'est de savoir que l'Europe doit
besoin de devenir souveraine d'un point
de vue énergétique et la seule source
qui peut nous faire devenir souverain et
éviter tout changement de situation
c'est de développer beaucoup plus
rapidement les énergies ne renouvelables
alors concernant la facture en Ursula
vanderline la prison de la Commission a
parlé voilà qu'il fallait travailler
pour des prix du gaz plus bas très
concrètement comment on fait quels sont
nos moyens de pression pour imposer
notre tarification à nos partenaires
elle a parlé de partenaires fiables
comme la Norvège et de partenaires
évidemment moins fiable comme la Russie
pour le gaz pour les partenaires
quelques pays quelques compagnies ont
encore des contrats long terme donc les
prix sont pas les prix du marché le plus
spot sont les prix négociés auparavant
bien sûr ils sont indexés avec quelques
indices mais bon c'est pas toujours le
prix qu'on voit sur les machines
internationales ce que je crois que la
Commission européenne va faire parler
beaucoup avec la commissaire kadissimson
très très impliqué dans ce problème de
commencer de discuter avec chaque
partenaire et trouver une bonne
équilibre entre le prix qu'on doit payer
et les quantités on peut pas plafonner
pour tous ces pays parce que autrement
ils font des investissements il le
divertissent quelques quantités qu'elles
peuvent vendre ailleurs c'est très
difficile pour le lnj pour le gaz
liquéfié mais
avec la plateforme commune d'acquisition
avec une bonne négociation on peut
baisser les prix qu'on prend de nos
partenaires fiables
spécialement ce qui le font par les
pipelines alors on a compris aussi que
dans ce plan il y avait une taxe sur les
super profits qui est censé rapporter
140 milliards d'euros à redistribuer par
les États membres 140 milliards d'euros
à la fois on va taxer ça c'est peut-être
pas très compréhensible pour nos
téléspectateurs on va taxer les plus
propres c'est à dire ce qu'ils font de
l'énergie euh
nucléaire ou alors renouvelable ou de la
biomasse cela et bien leur marge puisque
tout est calculé sur le prix du gaz a
été plus forte alors ce bout là on va
leur demander de contribuer puis
évidemment les moins propres les
fossiles aussi c'est ça c'est ça l'idée
exactement donc il y a deux mesures on
va plafonner le revenu de toutes les
sources d'énergie le prix de toute façon
par exemple pour les énergies
renouvelables de ce qu'on a pris de la
commission ce plafonnement va quand même
permettre de faire trois fois plus de
profit pour les producteurs de
renouvelables que l'année dernière donc
on ne parle pas d'un plafonnement qui va
vraiment annuler leur profil leur
activité on va permettre qu'ils aient
trois fois plus de profit que l'année
dernière mais le problème c'est que en
ce moment le prix il était complètement
explosé du fait d'avoir ce système de
fixation de prix qui fixe tout au prix
du gaz qui est le plus cher en ce moment
donc ce plafonnement est une première
mesure qui est nécessaire et
deuxièmement un impôt sur les sur les
super profits celui-ci seulement pour
les énergies fossiles donc pour gaz
pétrole etc donc voilà ces deux mesures
feront un revenu de 140 milliards ce qui
est très important pour voir aider les
ménages de ce qu'on parle finalement
c'est que le coût de l'inflation soit
réparti d'une façon juste ce qui n'était
pas normale c'est que nos citoyens
payent une facture énorme et le ménage
paye une facture de l'électricité énorme
et que le sept repère profit soit
explose donc c'est une façon
d'équilibrer un petit peu les coûts de
l'inflation je pense que ça va dans la
bonne direction sur ça je peux vous dire
que mon pays d'harmonie a déjà pris des
mesures beaucoup plus dures que ce que
c'est à annoncé aujourd'hui depuis le
1er avril tout ce qui est au-dessus des
90 euros au producteurs n'importe quelle
sorte de producteurs et imposité par 80%
et maintenant on a décidé aussi de
me poser on a décidé je suis parti de
partie du gouvernement je suis
vice-président je soutienne le
gouvernement qui ont large gouvernement
avec les deux principales parties du
pays centre droit et gauche pour les
traders
le laisse seulement 2% marge de profit
tout ce qui est au dessus de la
100% imposité et c'est bien accès oui
ils ont compris tout ce que beaucoup de
producteurs sont des compagnies d'état
ou l'État a une fonction importante un
grand mot à dire et cet argent est
utilisé pour le plafonnement et les
compensations que j'avais évoquées
plutôt alors ce qui est intéressant en
fait c'est qu'il y a plusieurs pays
compris de mesures quelques-uns pas tous
mais là avec les ce que la président de
la Commission a annoncé on va avoir une
mesure européenne donc on aura vraiment
un schéma d'application pour toi
justement tout toute cette question de
découplage du prix de du gaz et on va
aller en train de remettre à plat tout
le système énergétique on va faire une
grande réforme pour ça on a besoin de la
réforme de la de marché de l'électricité
moi je crois qu'on doit réviser où vous
êtes moins de doute de manière d'urgence
le système de coût marginal de
kumaximinal ou comme vous avez évoqué
tous les prix sur les marchés de
lendemain ce vers sur le plus haut prix
pour qu'il y a une demande c'est à dire
maintenant c'est le gaz donc pour avoir
une plafonnement une totale coordination
entre les prix on doit faire ça beaucoup
plus qu'on a fait aujourd'hui pour
découpler le gaz l'Espagne il a fait
c'était une succès mais il y a aussi une
plus consommation là de gaz donc il y a
quelque chose à régler aussi les mesures
vont dans la bonne direction mais on a
encore des difficiles temps traverser
dans les prochaines mois dans les dans
les mois qui viennent là ce sont on
parle on discute un des propositions
avancées par la Commission européenne il
va falloir que les 27 se mettent
d'accord est-ce que voilà les 27 vont
réussir à parvenir à un accord sur ces
questions ces mesures d'urgence face à
la crise énergétique il y a une réunion
dans quelques jours des ministres de
l'énergie européen il faut absolument
qu'ils le fasse le Parlement est très
clair sur ça nous soutenons les mesures
qu'a proposé à la Commission le Conseil
doit les adopter sur la taxe surprise
qui est intéressant c'est que la
Commission a utilisé une base légale que
l'article 122 c'est un peu technique
mais qui c'est un article qui impose une
façon de décider au conscient la
majorité qualifiée donc pas besoin de
pas le droit de veto à dynamique pas
d’unanimité pour la taxation sur le sort
profit à partir de la base légale qui a
été proposée ce qui est très important
pour que ça puisse être pas de Parlement
qui est un peu inquiétant pour nous pour
les parlementaires mais nous pouvons
accepter
l'urgence la nécessité et mais c'est
très important que la Commission les
États membres les 27 ministres de
l'énergie or leur remplaçant tient
compte des signal politique de Parlement
européen l'ONU demande au passage à
l'Union européenne d'éviter à l'occasion
de la crise ukrainienne et dans la
crainte que la Russie coupe le backgaz
d'éviter le retour massif aux énergies
fossiles très polluantes parce que c'est
aussi ce qui peut se passer à court
terme aussi le retour des centrales à
charbon et puis pourquoi pas le pétrole
etc est-ce que est-ce que ça vous le
craignez la fin du Green Deal sans qu'on
le dise alors moi je pense qu'il faut
parler de mesures d'émergence court
terme et de moyens long terme donc nous
nous sommes en tant que verre nous
comprenons les mesures pour ce qui qui
finalement on n'a pas le choix il faut
les faire mais après ce qu'on sera très
strict c'est que on n'utilise pas cette
situation d'urgence pour prendre des
mesures qui nous lient aux énergies
fossiles pour les prochaines 10 15
années et là on va voir tout un débat
sur les interconnexions du gaz dans
l'Union européenne sur les
usines permanentes de de gaz etc donc et
de charbon donc voilà si c'est des
mesures d'urgence pour maintenant
d'accord mais il faut absolument pas
encore revienne à nos plantes de
développement des énergies renouvelables
qui doit rester absolument la priorité
pour conclure vous aussi vous êtes
vigilance sur ce point-là oui oui bien
sûr c'est la stratégie du paoliu c'est
clair que une grande réponse c'est de
continuer de d'investir dans la
renouvelables dans l'hydrogène on peut
pas remplacer tu le gaz russe avec gaz
d'ailleurs le charbon a une très limité
fait beaucoup de mal à l'environnement
donc les renouvelables sont
la réponse pour mercure mais pour cet
hiver pour l'hiver de l'année 2023 c'est
difficile seulement avec des
renouvelables même si on va avancer
beaucoup et on va améliorer la
législation pour faire plus facile le
permising pour les investissements
renouvelables solaires et vont oui parce
que il va y avoir une agence d'achat de
l'hydrogène renouvelable parce que c'est
l'énergie du futur que que les Européens
doivent réussir à se répartir ça peut
être une source très importante
notamment pour l'industrie l'hydrogène
pour les ménages c'est plus compliqué
pour l'industrie ça peut être une source
en fait l'hydrogène c'est un vecteur
donc on produit de l'énergie à
l'hydrogène verte permet de la déplacer
donc en fait de l'hydrogène produit avec
les renouvelables qui puissent être
transportés par exemple en Allemagne
pour fournir leur puissance industrielle
ça peut être très bien une solution pour
le long terme bien sûr donc l'annonce
qui a été fait dans le monde va dans le
bon sens merci à vous d'avoir participé
à ce débat très complet très très dans
les fait on aura l'occasion on en
reparler dans les mois qui viennent avec
notamment cette réunion des ministres de
l'énergie européen dans quelques jours
le 30 septembre vous restez sur nos
antennes pour la suite des programmes à
très bientôt
[Musique]